and we're live
okay uh so I put up this warning slide
so I just want to before you get too
comfortable
um
I'm going to to basically go through
assembly for at least 45 minutes of this
presentation
okay I will not be offended if you get
up and leave now
but I will be offended if after 40 like
45 minutes of assembly you decide that
what the hell was I just a part of and
give me a red card so so this is a deal
here you can give me a red card for a
lot of things but you can't be because I
exposed you to assembly for 45 minutes
okay we're good all right yeah
hopefully you will understand
we'll see
tell me okay
um so the question was will I understand
well well that that that's the
experiment this is the first time I do
the taxable
we'll we'll see all right so uh the talk
is called uh return oriented programming
and introduction but to give you an
introduction to return oriented
programming we have to do a lot of
assembly
um so I'm not going to spend too much
time on my bio I'm a c plus programmer
I've worked places I have a master's in
computer science and my pronouns are she
there she they
okay so what we're going to do today is
what I affectionately call semi-artician
artisanal Rock which means that we're
going to use some tools to generate some
some stuff and then we're just going to
stitch it together ourselves and and and
it's basically to give you a feel for
the workflow
Okay so uh our our vulnerable uh
application is a tiny application that
all the model is right here I wrote the
the original version of it has only
three functions we don't really care
much about this application it has a
main function that calls authenticating
launch which is in the middle here
authenticating launch here is going to
call possibly launch missiles on top
there based on whether or not you give
it the right
password and this is Loosely inspired by
the movie War games which you might have
seen if you are
old and
and if you are young you should see it
and it's retro cool
um anyway so this is the application we
won't care too much about it but I'll
give you like the idea of it is that it
will print a prompt saying that you
should tell it like the secret uh you if
you tell it a wrong secret so for
example David it will say access denied
and then operation complete and it will
exit
if you tell that the right secret which
is Joshua which makes sense if you saw
the movie that you probably didn't see
and then you will say launching missiles
and then operation complete so that is
the basic functionality of this this is
how the the programmer when they wrote
the the program this is how they
intended it to work
um unfortunately it has a vulnerability
um
so we have a stack allocated buffer
right here and so when we read in uh
whatever the user said we are using C in
and C in will happily
right over the end of the buffer and go
on as long as you like
um so we have a stack uh buffer overflow
potentially here
now for to to make this fit on the slide
imagine that the buffers is small
um and so this is what the programmer
intended
and uh and what if we write to global
thermonuclear war yet again something
that would make sense if you saw the
movie
um
and then we end up in something that
that um that has been described as a
weird State and this is a whole Theory
and I'm not going to go into it but if
you want to to to look into that uh it's
a it's a it's a model for for thinking
about exploitation and it's called Uh
the weird machine
but anyway so the weird State here is
basically we're gonna crash right
uh because we did a buffer overflow and
it's probably Crypt of things on the
stack good chance we're going to crash
at this point
uh okay
I'm not going to explain anything more
about that application we probably don't
actually care about that application
from this point on
um uh we will care about the binary
itself
okay so in this presentation we're gonna
do a 32-bit mostly because
it's smaller fits better on the slide
and things like that uh also because uh
because the pointers are smaller we we
don't have a lot of null bytes in our
exploit and it helps because we're
reading a string doesn't really matter
it's it would be similar in 64-bit uh
for another application
Okay so
Intel 32-bit
and we're gonna go through uh how we
would design the the Shell Code which is
the the exploit that we want to run and
then we will go from that
to doing the same thing in rough okay so
again a warning this whole thing is
about exploitation
if that's not cheered Jam
the door is there go run run okay
um
okay so Shell Code shell code is a piece
of code typically a machine code so
think this these are bytes right just
regular bytes and that are delivered and
executed as a part of an exploit so we
are going to to try to run code
malicious code in some way
um
the reason why it's called shell code is
the traditional uh traditional use was
to start a shell so this was this was I
think the term was coined in the 90s and
uh and so and it was based on Linux
unix-like systems right so the idea was
to start like something like slash bin
slash sh which is what we will do today
[Music]
um
and real exploits it will generally do
something more advanced uh like
downloading something from the Internet
or connecting to a server to be ready to
execute a command or something you know
more but
um for this example we will just
start slash bin slash sh which is
probably Dash It's a Sim link to that
um so uh very very light introduction uh
to to to Linux and programs and so in in
Linux for the purposes of this
presentation it is useful to think that
we have a process and inside of that
process there is a program
so these two things think of them as
separate things so we have a process it
has virtual address space it has stuff
in it and a part of the things that are
in this address space is the program
that we are currently running
in this case our vulnerable program or
War Games program
if at some point we managed to execute
our Shell Code our Shell Code has uh its
only goal is to try to run X like ve
which is a system called on on Linux and
and and here we want to start slash bin
slash sh
if we execute
if we manage to do that inside of the
vulnerable program the whole
functionality of website ve is to blow
away our vulnerable program and replace
it with Slash bin sh but note it is the
same process
okay
that's the whole goal so our process our
program will turn in to a shell that has
a prompt where you can write a less
okay
yes
yes all right so the plan so this that
this is the plan for the entire
presentation
we will start by writing the C code for
the Shell Code that we want to do
then we're going to test it to make sure
it actually does what we intended it to
do I recommend you do this at any stage
throughout this process because it's
very easy to break them
and then we are going to to now that we
know what we want to do we're going to
write in line assembly that does what we
want it to do and that's again
we want to test that to make sure it
still does what we wanted it to do and
then we will go from that stage to
creating a rock chain and I'll show you
but I'll tell you what a Rob chain is at
that point that does the same thing as
we have done already and then we're
going to test that that still does what
we want it to do that is the entire plan
of the entire hour
all right okay
so we start with writing the C code
um so so
all code in this presentation is bad
code
um so the C code that we want is going
to look like this and I've split it into
multiple lines and and variables for for
clarity as we go
so the first part here is we're going to
want to close the file descriptor so
this is a file descriptive zero exactly
why we have to do this I don't have time
to explain and
but but I understand it now because
because Michael explained it to me
yesterday
um
so the second Point here is we're going
to call another system called called
open uh both of these we're doing uh to
make sure that that we are now reading a
standard in from the terminal but it
doesn't really matter the point is we
have two system calls
and then we have our exact ve so we have
three calls we need to make right
okay
so uh we will test it by compiling it
and even to compile it without warning
we actually have to pass a flag to turn
off some warnings and that's how bad it
is right
um but that's fine we don't care we're
gonna run it and it gives us a shell
prompt so here we could have written
like LS or something right
so this is the whole goal of this
program the program that we compiled was
the one that you saw which had the code
with the close open and exactly but when
you run it it gives us a show
yeah all right
so we now know what we want to do
um but how are we going to do this in
assembly
so on x86
um 32-bit the the calling convention for
for assist calls is
like this so basically calling
conventions case is what does the kernel
where does the kernel expect to find the
arguments to the sys call and how does
it know which Cisco you want to do
okay so that means we're going to be
dealing with registers
so the first register we're going to
care about is eax this is Intel is a
wonderful platform because it is
backwards compatible which basically
means it's kind of super mega
complicated
uh
um so eax is a register uh it is a
32-bit register but once upon a time
intel was a 16-bit uh platform so it
also has a part of it that you can use
the 16-bit names for and then you can
even use uh 8-bit names for for the
first byte and then the second byte so a
l and ah
we're not going to worry too much about
that I just want you to to know that it
is the same register we can just have
different names for parts of it
ebx has the same system
and ECX
and edx so the Sysco number is where
we're going to put it to say to the
kernel we want to do this Cisco
our first argument we have to pass an
ebx second end and ECX and then the
third in edx
okay so this is the plan this is what
we're going to spend
all our time on okay
all right so this was the C code for a
Shell Code let's look at the first two
lines
okay so close we want to do this we want
to to uh to close file the script to
zero
all right so so looking at the calling
convention foreclosed it says that the
syscall number for that is is uh hex 06
and
um which is six because you know even in
hexadecimal
um uh but and the the only argument that
it needs is passed in ebx and that's an
unsigned int and in our case Zero which
makes this relatively easy and the other
two registers are not in use for our
close
okay so we have our variable here and we
want to pass it and it's zero
so the the assembly for this is is
relatively short I I try to limit the
number of assembly instructions that I
have
so the first two lines we start on the
line one where we are doing an xor and
this is a way to set a register to zero
so after we've done the xor of eax it
will be zero on line two we are
moving the number
let's see if I can notice number six
into eax
so that means that after we've executed
these two instructions eax will have uh
the value of six I'll show you more on
the next slide and then we do an xor of
ebx because that's where we had to have
the file descriptor and now that's also
zero and then oh no wait a second and
then we do the final line line four and
where we do int 80. um hex lady and
that's how you uh invoke this call so
when we do that the kind of will go and
pick in the eax register see oh we're
doing syscall close Okay where is the
file descriptor it's an ebx and it will
take it and you know and it will do the
thing
all right uh so I will try to step you
through assembly by using uh slides I'm
very ambitious
um so we have we're going to fill our
first register that is the ex register
so we start by by doing xor of eax so
now the state of the register on the far
right there is is what it is currently
right so we've done an xor it's now zero
and then we move a hex 6 into eax and
now it is
and then we do uh for for the file
descriptor which is an ebx we will
extort it and it's zero then we do in 80
and it will
do the thing all right
that was your soft introduction to
assembly
okay it's only downhill from here all
right
um okay so then we are going to do open
and and immediately you can see that
this is going to be worse because we
have a pointer and a string
um
so uh so we have this is the code we're
going to try to do uh I'm looking at the
calling convention for open
it's going to expect this is called in
eax and then the pointer to the file
name so that means the address of where
the string begins it's going to be
expecting it in ebx
and then in ECX it wants Flags which is
an INT which is probably fine because
we've done an INT already so we're all
right and then in edx it's going to look
for a umot which is an in you know in
Disguise and so that's probably going to
be fine too so what is going to be a
problem for us here that we don't know
how to do is how do we get the pointer
in ebx and where is the string right
all right
so
a little more introduction to to
assembly okay so there is another
register I haven't told you about uh
which is the stack pointer register
into a snap pointer register is just
going to say this is currently the top
of the stack uh whenever you do a push
or a pop as a normal stack usage this
will be updated so when you push it will
you know
point to the new location and pop it and
point to the new location I am using
that language because on x86 the stack
is super weird and it grows towards
lower addresses and so so when it so
when you push it goes up
and when you pop it goes down and it's
just very confusing so I've just
eliminated that from the entire
presentation and we don't care
okay but the stack pointer register will
hold the address of the thing that is on
top of the stack so okay
um
yes so as we do it it will get updated
magically behind the scenes as the CPU
is executing our our instructions
and it also of course why not has the
same
kind of uh wonderful uh names so for
example on on x 64 or on x86 64-bit it
will it's called Uh RSP because uh
I don't know
uh I think the ESP became like extended
and then I don't know what happened with
the r
anybody know
no we don't care
um okay so this is going to be the
assembly
all right we'll we'll step to through it
like I did before but the point is the
first two lines are going to fill in eax
then this all of this is going to fix
the whole file name issue and then we're
just going to use xor 2 0 out ECX and
edx and then in 80 for the Cisco okay so
now the diagram got a little bit more
complicated so we're going to start with
filling out eax
so we start by x-raying it so we know
it's zero it's just
you probably don't have to do this but I
just tend to do this all the time
um so then we move uh five into eax and
now we're done with the ax because
that's all it needed we needed to put
the Sysco number in there and it's in
there so we're done
so then we move over to ebx which is
where all the fun happens
[Music]
um
so the first thing is we're going to
zero out ebx because we're going to be
using it for uh for working in
and we're going to push it and the
reason for that is
later this is where our string is going
to be so it's going to be on the stack
here and this first zero that we just
pushed is going to be on null Terminator
because you know it's fun all right and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to put this magic value into ebx but
this magic value isn't that magic
because what it actually is is a part of
a string and the ASCII characters for
that string so
it's backwards so this is slash so two f
is slash then 74 is T and then 74 is T
and then 79 is is slash or Y oh God this
slash t
t y That's the Way okay sorry I'm
dyslexic so me fix mixing up letters is
totally in character
um
no fun
um okay so so we have slash tt2y here
and then we're going to take the rest of
the string and do the same same trick so
we we put it we put part the ASCII codes
for some of the letters into our
register we can only do four at a time
because it's a 32-bit platform which
which divided by by 8 gives us four
characters on 64 bits you can do eight
characters in one registered
um okay so now we have the string it's
on the stack it's even null terminated
and so and we and I told you before that
when you push and you pop the the stack
pointer is updated which means the stat
pointers right now pointing to the top
of the stack which is the beginning of
our string which is what we needed so
then we take the stack pointer we put it
into ebx
and now we have a pointer to the string
in ebx
all right the rest of it you you know
already because everybody's paying
attention and so we just zero out these
two registers so that is ECX and edx and
we're done and that means we're gonna do
int 82 actually invoke The Cisco
all right
brings us to the last one now the fun
thing
when we get here is we have other
trouble here but some of the things here
we know already and so we know how to do
the string we have a plan for that uh
now we have these uh pointers to
pointers thing uh but we're just gonna
set everything to null so we're hoping
that's fine
and then we're going to do the exact ve
call but we know that if we just look up
the Sysco we can figure out the Sysco
number so
this is what we're going to do now
so we look up the calling prevention for
xxbe and it wants zero B in eax so
that's fine
then we want the pointer to the name
which is the slash bin slash sh in ebx
and then
um so that's the first parameter text
like the and then it wants an arc V and
if we were good citizens we would give
it to it but we're not so we're not
going to so it's just going to get null
and then in edx
uh we're going to do the same so just
know so keeping it simple for ourselves
here
so if you look at the assembly
um it's also long
uh first one is going to set the The
Cisco number in eax
put the file name in evx
and then we're going to zero out both
ECX and edx and then we're going to do
uh invoke The Cisco so
you know where this is going it's going
to be very similar to what we did before
so we're just going to put this is
called number in eax we're going to uh
build the string on the stack
and then we are going to put the the in
ebx we're going to put where the stack
pointer is now into evx so that is the
pointer and for people who never
understood C pointers before
you're welcome
um
okay and then uh in arcv we're just
going to zero out these two right so
we're done and we're going to do our
our Cisco
so far so good you're halfway okay
so we're gonna just uh test that to make
sure it actually works because Patricia
says a lot of things and so here is our
code we have our close we have our open
and we have our XXV
so if we uh then build that
and run it it gives us a shell prompt
all right so now we have we have
reproduced what we did in C code now we
did it in Intel the syntax assembly and
now we
move into
um the hard part
all right so the topic of this
presentation was not uh how do we write
Shell Code it is creating a rock or
teaching Rock oriented or return
oriented programming as a returner into
programming is an exploitation technique
that was designed specifically uh to to
get around the problem of the stack no
longer being executable and that means
that if you wrote Shell Code and put it
on the stack which you know in the good
old days was how you did things and then
we couldn't actually execute that code
because it was marked as not executable
and so this became you know a sand thing
uh so when your stack is not executable
what do you do
okay because we have our we have our
Shell Code this is what we want to
achieve but if we actually take the
bytes that represents this assembly and
we put it on to the stack we cannot
execute them
so the foundational idea of a drop or
maybe kind of two ideas so the first one
is that that there there is an
instruction called ret and that is the
instruction uh that uh is executed when
you return from a function
uh it has a a friend
called called call
and and and when you call uh when you
when you invoke call the call
instruction and it will put the address
of the next instruction on on the stack
and when you do red it will pop that
address off the stack and put it in the
instruction pointer yet another thing I
haven't told you about but I'll tell you
about
so so the idea here is that a rat will
cause you to jump back to where you were
called from and continue executing where
you were called from after the function
is done
hopefully after we've done this like 50
times this will make sense
um so
just as a visual
we are looking at a red instruction
being executed
so
right
let's write that on the bottom it just
says red if you can't see it it doesn't
matter and okay so imagine this is a
very small stack it has just two
addresses on it that's all that's there
um the stat pointer is pointing at the
top of the stack
and so
a red is being executed and so what
happens that means that what it ever is
on top of the stack is going to be
copied into the instruction pointer
and we did a pop so that means the stack
pointer has to go down so this is the
state
but when we when the instructions are
con continuously running right so when
we put a different address in the
instruction pointer it has to go there
and start executing code
and this address is somewhere
in executable memory so somewhere
there's an address and the instruction
pointer will jump there and start
executing stuff
in this case
stuff is xor eax
and so we're going to start by doing
that so the first part here is xor eax
and we know that that's going to set eax
to zero so far so good
then it's followed by a rat which means
we would go back to the stack pick
address two and so on but we're not
going to do that because now I'm going
to take it and make it worse
so imagine that we did this a lot right
so this is we have done a stack buffer
overflow and so imagine that you know
the the right hand side here is the
stack so uh so here you have uh the
stack allocated buffer
and then we have the return address so
the stack allocated buffer is in a
function right somebody it's it has a
function and in there there's a stack
allocated buffer when we oh no I'm
losing my
my mic there we go all right and uh once
we have an overflow it's going to
continue overflowing down the stack
uh and one of the things is going to
overwrite is this return address on the
stack which was the intention was that
we were going to return from to where we
were called and but we're malicious and
so we don't care what we do know is at
some point in in this vulnerable
application there is a rat and it will
go and grab whatever we put in this
location and it's going to put it into
the instruction pointer and jump there
all right so under here we have what I
call the rest of the ROM chain we will
get to it the point is that we don't
really care about the Overflow in the
beginning we care about the first
first one here so we're going to put an
address on the return address and that
is the address of the first what is
called a rock Gadget now the structure
of a rock Gadget is basically that you
have one or a few instructions
and then it's followed by a rat
all of the gadgets will have this
structure
so
right after we have Gadget number two
so if we think about what we did before
when
this address the gadget number one
address is copied into the the
instruction pointer execution will jump
over here it will execute these
instructions and then when it's done
it's going to do a red
which will means that it will go down
here pop this one into the instruction
pointer
now it will go over here do these
instructions oh it's followed by red oh
surprise oh there's another one okay so
we'll go over here and do that and so on
and so forth and that's how they're
chained together
so by just here on the stack all we have
are addresses right just a bunch of
addresses oh pointing is really hard
um okay so we just have a bunch of
addresses here the instructions are
actually somewhere else in memory
and the reason for that is we are in
we are in a process and it has a program
probably has a bunch of libraries too
and all of these the program code and
the library code and all of that has to
be in memory and that the the pages that
they're on has to be executable so
instead of actually putting code in here
we are just using the code that is
already in memory
and so we can jump around in memory from
place to place all we have to know is
where they are and as long as it has the
structure of instructions followed by
Rhett we can just chain them together
in our exploit and that gives us this
and this is called a rock chain
it's a chain of of addresses to Gadgets
in memory
all right
I'm surprised nobody's running away yet
okay
so to to put all of this together we we
have to put it into an exploit and so in
the beginning we're going to have this
padding because we don't care and the
first and so this is a rough chain and
the first Gadget is going to hit the
return address on the stack and then
after that this whole mechanism will
just drive itself because you jump to
that Gadget it has a red it will go to
the next Gadget it sounds of red it will
go to the next Gadget and so on
okay is this all right yes okay awesome
all right
um so you can script this uh to make
this string so so you will have
something like this so this is uh our
padding then we have a wrap chain in the
middle and then we just print out the
string and you can print it and write it
to a file or something
all right
okay but the cool thing is how do you
find all of these gadgets right we have
a binary but how do we know where and
where these things are
and the thing is this is actually
something that that lends itself to
automation
so there are lots and lots of tools to
try to find Gadgets in binaries and
we're I'm just going to show you one
which is called dropper but there are
many more and people are some many
people also make them themselves for fun
so the so if you
uh if you run wrapper on our binary so
our binary is called Target because it's
a great name and then we can even say I
want I want a Rob chain that doesn't
exact ve
and I can even say that these are bad
bites I don't want these bytes to occur
because you know here's we have a zero
zero and that's going to be a null
Terminator for a string that's not going
to be good and then 0 9 I think is a
space and zero B might be a tab no this
is 20 is a space but yeah but there are
different kinds of characters that will
do badly in our exploits so we say okay
we don't want those so can you create a
full rough chain
it's a tab there we go
someone who is making a code editor
would know that yes or an editor
um yes so basically these are the things
that we don't want and when we run that
on our file it loads gadgets because
I've run it already and it will say Okay
I I can make a rough chain for this is
called xxve and
it's processing and it got all of the
gadgets it needs and at the bottom it
says this is called Gadget found
and
what it ends up making is something
that I'll just cut off some of it in the
middle here so it's a python script
right like I showed you earlier it
includes a little bit that I'm not going
to go through too much here it's
basically so that the addresses you can
rebase them to different kinds of Base
addresses if you if
but it doesn't really matter so well
don't don't care about it the basic idea
is what we want to look at is the drop
chain inside right so this
pink section here in the middle
all right
so this is what it looks like
um
it looks kind of intimidating but we
will go through it many times
um so the basic idea here is that we
have these addresses and these are the
addresses of the gadgets so this is the
first address if I go back and forward
you can see it occurs
occurs three times so we have it's here
and here and then down there at the
bottom and it has hopefully given us
what the instructions is next to it so
this is a pop eax Rhett pop eax will
then take whatever's on top of the stack
and put it into eax and then the Reds
will well it will do what Rhett does
and so here we have uh the the second
Gadget and it does lots of different
pops and then the third one is going to
actually uh write something to memory
we'll get to it
and then there's an extor of eax uh a
pop into ebx ECX
and then a bunch more Pops and the next
door and down here we have a negation of
eax I'll get to that and the final one
is that it might be hard to see in the
back it's just int 80 red
where you don't really you know yeah so
so that's going to invoke The Cisco so
these are the nine gadgets or we can put
them up here
these are the nine uh Snippets of code
that I found and it uses some of them
several times uh to to X to to chain
together the what it wants to do and
remember what we want to do is we want
to fill these four registers with what
we need right eax ebx ECX and edx
and and that's all we need to do before
we do the into 80 which is going to
execute the system call
and these are the instructions that it
uses in the generated payload
so
ready
okay so this is the stack this is where
we're going to have our wrap chain and
these are the registers that are going
to be in use uh this is uh where we're
gonna have the three first uh
um the three three first gadgets at the
bottom
um
this is a memory where we're going to be
writing to
and up here is the instruction pointer
all right this is the beginning of our
rough chain
all right so our stack pointers here and
for this section I'm not going to move
the stack pointer for every time we do a
pop we're just going to move it for
every Gadget because if not it's going
to be very messy
so just imagine it moves kind of down as
we go all right so the first thing is
this is going to go into our instruction
pointer because a red hat is being
executed
so that goes into the instruction
pointer the instruction will jump down
here and it will execute a pop eax
now because it's doing a pop eax and you
have imagined because you're a helpful
audience that the stack pointers move
down here it will pop this value that's
here on the stack
let's do it like this that is here in
the stack which is this string I have
helpfully translated the ASCII for you
okay excellent and so we will then move
that value into eax
all right
next one
this uh Gadget well the address of the
gadgets will be put into the instruction
pointer the instruction pointer will
jump down here and this one actually has
a lot of things we don't care about we
actually only care about the pop edx but
it does pop edx ebx
e-s-i-e-d-i EBP lots of stuff we don't
care about
and so what we're going to do it does
the pop edx
and first
and so we have helpfully provided here
the value that we want
to put into edx and so we're going to
pop so edx is the first pop then pop ebx
and we're just going to put trash there
ECI trash EDI trash EBP trash we don't
care
we got the edx and the important thing
to notice here is that we have a gadget
that does more than we want but we can
just kind of provide
trash for those
um
exactly what trash means tends to to uh
to differ from different types of tools
in in rocker it's dead beef but on lots
of them they're just A's or something
okay
the stock pointer is down here
and that will
then because we have a red remember this
is I'm just going to remind you down
here in the corner there's a rat and so
when this red happens it will go and
pick up the next address uh put it in
the instruction pointer
and this
I'm not going to go through too much in
detail here but but the the this
instruction is going to take the pointer
that is in edx
which is this pointer here and if you
see is one
ca060 which is the same as as this thing
over here
um
and it's going to put there the value
that is in eax which is this little
string
right so this is what it does it writes
what is an eax here
all right so we'll leave that because we
want that and we do the rest of our
blockchain
and so
let's do this how are we doing on time
just so I know
okay we're good all right
um
so we do the first Gadget put and put it
in the instruction pointer jump to where
it is and it's a pop eax so that's great
so we put that in eax
then we go to the next one and it is the
same one we had before so here it's
going to do a pop into edx
this value that we hopefully provided On
The Stack
and that is also an address note
if we look at the address it matches
this address here
and so if you if for for people who are
sitting and doing math in the audience
you can see that this is four bytes
after this one
um
and then we just do deadbeat for
everything else
and then we move to the last Gadget
which is going to
to write the value in eax to the address
in edx
all right
so now we're here see this
we still need an old pointer people uh
okay and no Terminator Okay so
we're gonna do it again very similarly
I'll do faster this time so we have zero
and eax we need the pointer to where
we're going to write it in the edx and
then we are going to right there and so
we are writing zero over there now we
have a string in memory thank goodness
all right
okay so that brings us to to the
registers because we still haven't done
the registers we have the string in
memory but we don't have and we haven't
done the Realtors yet but that's faster
so uh the first Gadget is just going to
pop uh whatever is on top of the scan
stack into ebx and we have the address
there the next one is going to do uh
same thing for ECX
in with the values and then we have uh
that we need to do it for edx which has
the very convoluted weird one which
writes dead beef everywhere
um no it's a different one that also has
right step beef and then the
here we are going to pop into eax
because we need the syscall number but
in this case because we had these bad
bytes and things it does a little trick
which is kind of uh fun if you like um
choose complement math which if you
don't you don't care so
um so it writes a totally different
value than we want and then it does a
different instruction which is a
negation of the value that's in eax
which will magically transform into the
value we want
so
that's fun all right so this is the this
is the state we have managed to fill in
all of the registers we have a string
it's in memory we have the address to
that string in in ebx like we were
supposed to and so let's have a little
bit uh so the last instruction we're
going to do is
is invoking the syscall
and that's it right so if we look at
what we needed we needed the Cisco
number and eax and we have it we need
the string the pointer to the string in
ebx and we have it and then we're just
going to actually pass
pointers to null in edx and and ECX
um
and then we invoke the syscall and Magic
happens
yes just a quick question so I I got
lost at some point when you invoke the
Roper or Roper you just gave it the
exact ve argument as far as I could see
but somehow yeah okay let's let's so the
question is uh how did the the rougher
bit go so I'll let's just have another
look because I split it over several
slides there we go so the the actual
call
uh is this
okay so here uh the first parameter is
as file Target so Target is the name of
the binary and it's in current directory
yes that is the war games by the way uh
and and then chain exactly you just
because it can make different types of
chains some for Windows and and stuff so
you have to indicate which one you want
and there is I think some some
indication that they want to in the
future be able to support many different
system calls but I don't think they
actually fully support them uh and then
the the the last argument is the bad
bites and those are the ones that we
don't want and if for people who were
were wondering about the negation notice
that one of our bad bytes is zero B
which is the syscall number which is
unfortunate so with the negation we can
still have it because it's uh
it's there
you want to start a show so so yes I the
traditional so this is what I've shown
you the exact PE of Slash bin slash sh
is like
the traditional thing so this is like
what so so one of the things that you
will see when people do exploitation for
example on Windows uh on Windows they
will often start the calculator
and that's just to prove that I have I
have code execution I managed to start
the calculator it also looks better on a
video like you might have seen that I
made like the show prompt really big
that's to make it impressive
but but on Windows they pop they they
start the calculator and they actually
call it pop calc
and make it sound cool
um okay so
um yeah let's yeah but it was a very
very uh it's it's better to go back all
right so this is where we were we filled
in all of our registers
life is good
okay but for people who are following
along
we didn't only want to do exactly we had
other stuff we wanted to do
yeah so it was it created a rough chain
for us that did the xfbe but we actually
wanted to do the close and the open
first
and so that it doesn't we don't have a
rock chain for that
so if we look at close uh we have some
things that we need we need to to put
our Cisco number in eax and we need to
put a zero in ebx
and we can use some of the existing
gadgets that we found earlier pop eax is
going to be nice and negating of eax is
going to be nice so we can in this case
put the Cisco number in eax with these
and we need the Cisco instruction which
is the into 80. but we are missing uh
the xor of ebx that was not one of the
things that was created by rapper
all right
if we look at open we can use almost all
of the gadgets because it was very
similar right we have the string and all
of those things we just put in a
different string
uh so most of it we can use
but we are missing the zeroing out of
ECX and the zeroing out of edx
so
if we look at XIV of course it has all
of the gadgets because that's what the
what dropper generated so it has so it
can do exactly so what we are missing is
three gadgets
so xor of ebx X or ECX and xor of edx
thankfully though rapper has another API
and that is that you can search for
Specific Instructions that you want so
here we do what we want is an xor of ebx
and when we do that it will search for
gadgets that do that but maybe do other
things as well and so you and so it will
search for many different things and
some of these might be fine you might be
able to fiddle them to do what you want
but it would be nice if you get one that
is exactly what you want
so down here we have at the bottom xor
ebx ebx red which is exactly what we
want and so
all three of these are actually present
in the binary when we search for them so
now we have uh have those addresses and
we can use them in our exploitation
so
we're going to put all of those together
in this long string I'm not going to
show you that
so that when it is executed it will do
the close and it will do the open and
then it will do uh do the exact ve
and uh
in this case here in the script it's
going to write all of this out to a file
so this is the long string little
padding and then the whole wrap chain
and it's going to put that into a file
then we start our our Target application
in g2b because we want to to see what
happens because you know like 99 of the
time when you're doing exploit
development the target crashes
um that's kind of hard like most of the
job is trying to make it stop
um
so so then we're going to say that we
want the target to read from our
blockchain file instead of standard in
and so we oh I forgot to change the name
here it was called the advanced Roper
anyway and it starts the application it
says access granted because apparently
we managed to do that much when we
overwrote uh the stack launching a
negative number of missiles I'm not
exactly sure how that works but that
would be really nice
um and then it says access denied
because everything is broken at this
point and then it suddenly GDB says oh
wait
this process is now running a different
program
it's no longer running you know the war
games program it is currently running
slash user slash bin slash Dash and
that's because on on this machine slash
bin slash sh is the Sim link to to dash
which in this case is in user bin Dash
and then
we get a shell prompt which is down here
for people on the back thank you
so
hopefully uh hopefully I I
managed to to show you how how return
oriented programming works
and um
because we got shell
yay okay and then pause for the show
thank you
and that is the whole talk so now we
have a good 10 minutes for questions or
nine minutes
okay yes
yes
okay so the question is what is a gadget
or
so this is let's see this is a gadget so
somewhere in the binary somewhere is the
sequence of bytes that when interpreted
as uh instructions would be interpreted
as xor of ebx followed by a red
the interesting thing about x86 well the
Intel platform is that it has variable
length instructions and so that means
that this instruction doesn't
necessarily have to be in the binary but
the sequence of bytes we're looking for
has to be somewhere on one of these
executable Pages which means that this
could actually be a substring of the
totally different instruction
um which is is one of the fun things
about about the Intel platform yes
and the comment is that the bigger the
boundary the easier it is to find the
gadget yes so you are kind of cheating
by doing C plus thank you
okay so he's saying saying okay so so
the the thing the the question is you
need to be able to find all of these uh
gadgets and that means the more binary
the better and uh so you have more to
look at right to find exactly what you
want and hopefully something that fits
well
um and that means you need a bigger
binary and and we have a you know a very
small program and he says that I'm
cheating because I'm using C plus plus
which is going to bloat the binary which
is rude
but but yes that is an issue uh yeah
okay so then okay what do you do when
you can't find the energy you need uh so
in real life binaries are quite big so
it's not an issue uh most of the time I
I think people have done research on it
says that they are men they can find a
touring complete set of Gadgets in
almost all binaries
um yes
uh so but for me that if you have a very
small program uh then then for for for
educational purposes that might be an
issue and so what I do sometimes is I
cheat and I I put uh the the
instructions that I want in in a C file
as inline assembly and I call it a
gadget farm and then I just compile it
with my other thing and then I find them
by Magic
yes
well okay with aesthetically linked
program be less secure than a
dynamically linked program
um
it would be bigger because when you have
a statically linked program basically
you're taking all of the libraries and
just putting it into your binary so
there's more code right but at the same
time uh with the statically designed
program all of your binaries all of your
libraries are inside of you which gives
you other types of security issues like
for example what if you have a
vulnerability in your open SSL library
that you have now statically linked into
this binary right if it was on the
system then somebody might have update
it to a new version and then you might
be so it's it's all technical questions
through I have one answer and that is
it depends
yes
we have access
itself
what's the process there to develop
okay so so if you're going to develop a
wrong chain for a binary that is running
on a remote system yeah yes uh how do
you do that okay so the the most common
way to do that is to reproduce the
system and so if you can and you can do
that oftentimes by by by looking at the
services running there will leak enough
information about the the version and
things like that so you might be be able
to to uh figure out the versions of the
things that you need to to attack then
you set up a local system that is the
same uh and and that's kind of how you
would work it it makes things harder but
then you basically you do all your
development and and debugging locally
and then and then you try to do it
remotely but still with the VMS until
you have nailed out all of your issues
yeah
any yeah
okay is there something you can do
to mitigate against this yes uh there
there was uh specifically uh one uh one
thing that has been been uh was
developed by by Microsoft ads called
control flow garden and in control floor
guard you basically are recording when
you compile all of the the the things
that you are allowed to jump to so so
remember we have addresses we're just
jumping randomly uh and control for
guard it just makes a table of all the
things that you're allowed to jump to uh
to so that you can't do this random
jumping everywhere of course
then somebody had to figure out a way to
to do it anyway and a new technique was
developed and it was called a block
oriented programming where it uses it
takes the table from control flow Garden
creates a graph tries to figure out
again like I want to do this instruction
in this instruction and then finds a
path through the graph that's that
manages to fill the registers with the
things that you want because you know
we're programmers and that's how we do
things yes
any more questions
okay thank you thank you so much for
coming
[Applause]